This story is one of those stories where you
really have to look at the details to know
what what is the story?
Is this a big story or not?
The the story is that Democratic vice presidential
nominee Kamala Harris has now confirmed that
if she and Joe Biden are elected, that they
would decriminalize the use of marijuana at
the federal level.
Now, everybody went crazy for different reasons.
Kamala Harris outlined at an event through
Facebook Live with ABC.
The broad strokes of the proposal.
And it includes, among other things, which
I will get to full federal decriminalization
of the use of marijuana.
You had some people on the right who are just
furious, who say decriminalizing marijuana
use is the first step to anarchy.
It's the first step to rampant out of control,
addiction and chaos everywhere.
Biden must be stopped.
And then you have people on the left who are
saying, this is so lame.
This is so centrist.
Decriminalize use.
We must legalize use.
We must decriminalize small scale dealing
of marijuana.
This is way too right wing for me.
So what's the truth?
The truth is one that most people don't want
to accept, which is progress typically comes
in steps.
I believe we need full legalization of use,
regulate it, tax it.
Selling it on the street becomes sort of like
selling illegal cigarets and you deal with
it like a health issue instead of a criminal
issue when you have substance abuse issues.
Without question, though, a federal decriminalization
would be a big deal, but it would just be
one step with another four years of Trump.
We get nothing.
We just get nothing.
Simply nothing, period.
Now, there are also people mad that a flip
flopped Comilla used to be against legalization
and decriminalization 10 years ago.
Well, she's changed her view and we should
applaud that.
In other words, there are lots of elected
officials who eventually came around to better
positions and they shouldn't be shamed for
that.
Some, what some people call flip flopping
sometimes is flip flopping merely for for
sort of political posturing purposes.
But sometimes you evolve because you actually
get more information or you mature.
You come around to the right point of view.
So when 2019, she sponsored legislation which
would federally d schedule cannabis, that
would would be a great thing to do.
And overall, we should be glad that she changed
her mind.
Now, let's be real.
There is a major gap between decriminalization
and legalization.
If you legalize cannabis, you can regulate
it similar to alcohol and tobacco.
You can tax it to decriminalize cannabis merely
removes criminal sanctions when you offend
or break the law.
Cannabis could remain illegal.
Possession above a certain amount could result
in civil fines or drug education or treatment
instead of criminal prosecution.
So it is not a panacea.
It is not the end point, but it is a step
forward.
Joe Biden, by the way, wouldn't just federally,
federally decriminalize, but according to
his Web site, would are also expunge prior
cannabis use convictions.
That's a good thing.
That gets a bunch of people cleared.
It's certainly not going to impact low level
dealers who are sitting in prison.
And we need to deal with that.
But it is a step forward.
Joe Biden also supports the legalization of
medical cannabis at the federal level, but
again, would leave decisions about adult recreational
use up to the states.
So, listen, this is one of those times where
we just have to be very real and pragmatic.
If Biden gets to do what is on his platform,
it would be the most progressive federal cannabis
policy in the history of a sitting president,
period.
I get that we want to do more.
I get that many of us feel that it's 20/20
and this is not enough.
And we need to be catching up to other countries
that have dealt with this in in more progressive
ways already.
But if Biden gets in and he does this stuff,
the U.S. would be as progressive at as it
has ever been when it comes to the regulation
of cannabis.
If they do this, it will lead to more legalization
in more states for sure.
There will be states who, if they see, decriminalized
federally expunging convictions, so on and
so forth.
There will be states that maybe right now
are 53 to 47 against legalization that will
say look at look what's happening federally.
Let's do it.
You know, other states have done it, Massachusetts
did it, Colorado, etc., this will be a major
step forward.
And of course, we want more, but let's not
miss the forest for the trees.
And much like with health care, is Biden's
idea perfect?
Of course not.
Does Biden's platform on health care fix all
of the problems we've identified?
Not even close.
But if Trump got his way, 30 million people
would lose coverage.
OK, let's not miss the forest for the trees.
We're going to have more on this on our Instagram
account.
Follow us there at David Pakman show.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman for
pictures from my vacation, which I will talk
about on today's bonus show,